Film Courage: One great thing I just heard
you say was wherever we go, we take ourselves
with us.
Rob Reiner: True.
Wherever you are, there you are.
It’s a line I remember from Buckaroo Banzai.
But I’ve always loved that line because
that’s true.
Film Courage: It is true and for better or
worse you can’t get away from yourself.
Rob Reiner: You can’t!
But hopefully you want to be around yourself.
That’s the key!
If you like yourself, then no matter where
you go, it’s okay.
Film Courage: Right!
And I know the film’s protagonist Lyndon
struggled with various self-esteem issues
which was interesting to see [in the film]
one statement was so fascinating in that he
said [paraphrasing] there are show ponies
and field horses.
Rob Reiner: Right, there are show horses and
work horses.
He said he thought of himself as a work horse.
And the reason he was is because he knew that
he was not a show horse.
He was not somebody that you would immediately
take…he wasn’t overly handsome, worried
about his appeal or whatever that John or
Jack had, right?
But so if he was going to be liked and in
the case of Lyndon, he was so insecure, he
desperately wanted to be loved.
The way to make that happen was to work so
hard to deliver results for people that they
would love him for.
Film Courage: You did an excellent job of
showing these various scenes where it was
unspoken but you could see what was going
on whether it was the crowd scene [as he’s
shaking hands and being upstaged by John].
When you are directing a scene, how are you
thinking about a character arc in each take?
Rob Reiner: Well the way I look at any film
that I do is there’s a spine that goes through
a film and you decide ahead of time what is
the story you want to take?
And in the case of Lyndon, it’s Lyndon.
So this is the story of who is this guy?
So every scene has to attach to the spine
in some way.
In other ways, each scene you will learn a
little bit more about who this guy is.
So by the end of the journey you say “Okay,
I got a full picture of who he is.”
Film Courage: You didn’t play a[n acting]
role in this film?
Rob Reiner: You know, I didn't because first
of all I don’t really like acting and directing.
I find it splits my mind attention, my focus.
I’ve done it but I don’t love it.
And there was no real part for me.
Who am I going to play?
I can’t be Jack.
I’m too…I’m a Jewish guy from the Bronx.
I can’t be Bobby.
I’m too big.
Film Courage: So you’re known for a fast-paced
directing style.
Would you say it’s sped up over the years
as the world has sped up, or you’ve actually
slowed down and you’ve been a contrarian?
Rob Reiner: No…I’ve actually have had
to speed it up because I have less time to
make films.
Every film that I’ve ever made would never
get made in a studio.
They are not the kind of films studios make
so I have to finance them independently and
whenever you finance a film independently,
you have a strict budget.
You have a short amount of time to make the
film.
So I love doing crossword puzzles.
I love puzzles and I try to figure out what’s
the best way to get this done in the most
economic way possible.
Film Courage: Having been on both sides of
the camera, from being an actor what were
a few things that you said as a director,
I swear I’m never going to do this.
Whether it’s 50 takes of one scene, not
showing actors dailies, etc.?
Rob Reiner: The main thing I say is I would
never ask an actor to do something I couldn’t
do.
And I’m not the best actor in the world
(I’m a decent actor, but I’m not the best).
The people who I get, who I ask to play these
parts, they are all better than me at what
they’re doing, at the part that they are
doing.
So I know if I can do that and make the transition
I ask them to make or play an emotion in the
scene, I know they can do it because I can
do it.
I would never ask him to do something I couldn’t
do.
Film Courage: I think you’d said 10, 20
years ago you couldn’t do this film.
Why now?
Rob Reiner: Well, more than that.
It was more than 20 years ago.
When I think about Lyndon, it was the 60’s
and I was over 18, during this time.
So I didn’t like Lyndon.
I mean I saw him one way, as my enemy, the
guy who could send me to have bad things happen
to me, so I didn't like him and it wasn’t
until I matured, I spent time in politics.
I had a job in California for seven years,
that I started to really understand and appreciate
what he was able to accomplish.
And it’s only at that point where I said
“Well, let me take a look at this guy”
because it’s almost like if you look at
it’s like a tale of two terms.
He’s got the overseas invasions and then
he’s got his domestic achievements, which
(except for the 1930’s) is probably the
greatest of all time and had it not been for
his overseas actions, he probably gone down
as one of the greatest terms of all time.
Film Courage: We have a lot of first time
filmmakers who watch our videos.
What would you tell a first time filmmaker
about getting their film made?
Rob Reiner: Well here’s the beauty…when
I was starting out…you know…making films,
the materials, that are used to make a film
are expensive.
It’s the camera, there’s film stock, there’s
editing, there’s lights (all this stuff).
Now, to make a film, all you need is an iPhone,
a Smart Phone and your computer to edit.
I mean you can use available light.
So there is no excuse to not just making a
film.
Write the script, get your friends who you
think can act and actually make a film and
it doesn’t cost very much.
So…you know… it’s that…”Just do
it!”
It’s a Nike thing…[off camera laughter].